yes of course it has been a very long
day but i do have all the details of
those sentences and they were given
different sentences depending on their
involvement of the crimes so we'll start
with sebastian zimac and michael
lesinsky so they were believed to be the
masterminds behind this criminal
organization they were both sentenced to
seven years in prison now it's believed
that between them they managed to make
hundreds of thousands of pounds via
these sex workers often driving them
around from brothel to brothel from
hotels and to clients personal
businesses as well making hundreds of
thousands of pounds so they were both
sentenced to seven years the next one in
that hierarchy was griego burowska he
was sentenced to three years and nine
months in prison i was believed that he
had worked on reception and all also had
some involvement in in transferring some
of these victims from a to b next was
raphael lasky now he had said that he
was actually an uber driver
before the pandemic he had had thousands
of reviews and that made thousands of
journeys but fell on hard time during
covid and therefore took a driving job
with this criminal organization and i'd
have just conceded that compared to the
other defenders he hadn't been involved
as much but she did sentence him to 18
months in prison however he spent 11
months in remand already so he will be
released on time served and finally mrs
anna zimmark that's the wife of
sebastian zimac she was sentenced to two
years but had that sentence suspended
now it was thought that whilst her
husband had been extradited to poland
for a similar conviction that she had
taken over the business with the help of
uh michael le czinski and throughout the
the 10-week trial we've heard some
horrifying accounts from victims who say
that they were abused both physically
and emotionally and of course sexually
some of them said that they had their
money withdrawn from them and if they
dare refuse to have sex with the client
they were also starved we have heard of
one particular victim she said that
she'd already experienced a horrendous
childhood growing up she had fled from
poland to britain in the hopes that she
could restart her life she then
experienced abuse at the hands of a
brothel and it reached out to one of
these criminals to for help to get her
out of that situation instead she was
put to work straight away she actually
spoke to sky news and she told us of her
experience of being trafficked
the first guy he was polish and he was
60 years old six zero for me that was
very bad because the stepfather who
raped me he was also very old i don't
want to stay with this guy and i said to
him i don't want to do this and he
didn't listen he just said i had to go
to the room with him and that's that
and the metropolitan police have been
working on this case for a few years now
it's been a huge investigation they said
that they managed to safeguard more than
130 women but had found that more than
300 women were likely to be in a similar
situation sky news also spoke to the
detective inspector on this case and
this is what he had to say
i'd describe them as opportunistic
and
i think what what what they've done in
this case is particularly evil
um and having seen
uh multiple cases of this kind of
offending it
yeah it's
i just yeah i just i find it completely
evil
and so i am pleased that we've been able
to bring them to justice um and
hopefully as i say bring some closure to
the victim
in this case
and while sentencing the judge said that
many of the victims were treated as
though they were worthless they said the
victims had been emotionally physically
and psychologically dimensioned would
take long time for them to be able to
recover from this and interestingly she
also spoke about the different types of
victims she spoke about the ones that
knew that the abuse wasn't right but she
also spoke about the ones that weren't
quite sure and that on the surface
looked as though they had agreed with
the abuse that they had endured and this
is something that the police also want
to reference as well they've made it
clear that among us every time we go to
a nail shop and and visiting our high
streets that we have to be a little bit
more vigilant that there are vulnerable
people all around us and i suppose this
case serves as a reminder of just how
vulnerable some of these people are and
as i say all five of those people have
been convicted and sentenced